big numbers kelly olynyk since  coming over in that trade that sent  victor oladipo to miami he's put up some  big numbers  with houston and a foul called on avery  bradley in the backcourt  known for his defense and he and james  harden having  a conversation is it friendly  i always wait for like the little smile  yeah there was no  [Applause]  three seconds two seconds  harden is fouled avery bradley over  playing  got his hand on it and then got  stuck with his hand in the cookie chair  yeah i was going to say  reach in and avery bradley  saying that harden grabbed his arm  i believe so let's take a look  yeah harden does a nice job of hooking  the armor bradley  i mean the man knows how to get to the  free-throw line  and harden would probably tell you this  is his guide hand going up the ball as  he's going to shoot and  bradley's arm was in the way harden was  thinking he's going to get three  i'm getting three right no  two